is there drama between addison ray and
the demilios
keep my name out to malcolm b for free
addison
issued an apology to charlie demilio
after the tick-tock shade room instagram
account resurfaced some mean comments
about charlie
that addison liked back in november it
is
scary to think about the bad side of
things comments included charlie not
deserving to be verified
and another saying she wasn't the
prettiest girl on tick-tock
no matter what anyone says i do what i
do for all of these people that say
i inspire them or i'm the reason they
got into dance lessons it just makes
everything so worth it and it makes me
so happy that
i can say like i'm helping people in the
little way i am like it just it means
the world to me
addison admitted to liking the comments
saying she didn't know charlie at the
time
and that there's no excuse for her
actions
she says her self-confidence was at an
all-time low
after an extremely toxic relationship
i actually was in a really really long
serious relationship before any of this
happened to me
yeah so um i've learned a lot from that
relationship and it was a really big
part of my life for about five years so
it was just like
it was different to like branch off to
this and so now that i am
in this position it's just like me time
you know like i spend a lot of my time
in relationships so it's like
now is my time to grow and like chase my
dreams on my own and it's kind of what
i'm doing
quote i was fully depressed and hated
myself
i thought i was worthless without him
after five years of being together
i searched for compliments and love from
others because i couldn't love myself
without him
it's so gross and makes me really sad to
think about to this day
but i do know that i've loved and
supported charlie since the day i met
her
when you put those things in out into
the world like that always comes back to
you and like if you are
looking at things in a negative way or
like not on a good side of it it's like
it does affect you in a negative way
charlie and addison have since met and
formed a friendship
addison says charlie deserves everything
she has today
quote i already told her that she
doesn't need to forgive me
while charlie hasn't publicly responded
to the apology
her sister dixie had some words on
twitter that seemed to be about the
addison drama
she tweeted the jealousy oh my god
charlie deserves better family first and
that's that
and last thing i'm gonna say i love my
friends but my family comes first and i
will not apologize for sticking up for
my sister
i have love for everyone i am just very
frustrated
right now i feel like it just brought
our relationship
like a lot a lot closer but
before we start labeling this and
addison vs dixie dimelio showdown
dixie posted this tick tock today of the
two reacting to the story
hey what's going on